sì grazie
buongiorno a tutti che maturi auschwitz
sono un insegnante di matematica e
scienze in una scuola media
mi piace moltissimo al mio lavoro a
scuola mi diverto e sogno
la scuola che avrei voluto facessero a
me per cui cerco di giocare con ragazze
cerco di capire il loro linguaggio e
soprattutto di imparare da loro
io sono quasi un dinosauro digitale ho
imparato a usare il computer perché il
mio professore all'università mi ha
detto quello il computer quello del
libro dell'istruzione la tesi si fa con
il computer
io sono forestale la mia sono laureata
in scienze forestali e quella tecnologia
gran poco in comune però scoperto che la
tecnologia mi aiuta e la tecnologia mi
permette di coinvolgere i ragazzi in
quello che faccio e ci divertiamo
insieme per cui è da quando lavoro in
questo modo non metto più la donna
quando vado a scuola perché mi siedo sul
pavimento perché ho insegnato anche
l'università agli insegnanti le nuove
tecnologie per l'inclusione e posso
avvertito le aule dell'università
cattolica perché negli ambulacri eravamo
sul pavimento con con i colleghi a
provare diciamo delle ge che permettono
di includere proprio tutti dalle ragazze
i talenti per cui chi è particolarmente
bravo trova un modo per fare di più ma
chi ha delle difficoltà a un opportunità
per sperimentare per costruire per
creare
ma non solo tecnologia vedete c'è c'è un
ananas pavia mostrerò io insegno
matematica e sono forestale
normalmente le le aule nostre sono così
non questi banchi i banche sono
migliorate però contro molto spesso con
dei colleghi che dicono no no
manteniamo l'ordine perché li vedo in
faccia posso controllare la situazione
in realtà quando si lavora in maniera un
po diversa
le classi sono spazi diverse sono
potrebbe essere anche il bosco potrebbe
essere qui fuori e queste bellissime
prati perciò i banchi andrebbero
utilizzati quando serve scrivere perché
si scrive quando dobbiamo appoggiarci
per lavorare per costruire però sono
soltanto una delle cose che che ci
interessa perciò a scuola e non solo a
scuola anche a casa perché questo modo
di lavorare è un qualche cosa che porta
delle idee che che continuano cioè si
pensa ai paesi va oltre lavoriamo con
non so concerto per cipolle tortellini
con le mafie ma che per insegnare dei
linguaggi di linguaggi nuovi ma anche
per creare il telefono il telefono mi
permette di portare riportare il codice
anche diciamo al teenager che di solito
lo usa soltanto per scappare now
affascinante umanoide non solo
tecnologia ma anche un modo per capire
l'interazione uomo macchina per capire
il rispetto che dobbiamo avere per la
tecnologia perché c'è anche un senso
etico in questo è bene o male la scuola
che a me piace è una scuola
nella quale c'è c'è molto di sociale
nella quale si costruisce anche la
comunità che noi vorremmo avere
ovviamente queste sono le cose
la tecnologia c'è dappertutto tranne che
a scuola adesso in realtà abbiamo
possibilità di chiedere finanziamenti
della possibilità di immaginare procede
per i finanziamenti non sono per
comprare solo tecnologie sono per
rivedere gli ambienti gli spazi per
pensare progetti nuovi
ma soprattutto per contaminare a quanti
più colleghi possibili perché un
insegnante o due insegnanti 10
insegnanti non sono abbastanza
se si è in tanti si riesce proprio a
condividere e soprattutto anche l'idea
di condividere le risorse risorse aperti
insegnare ai ragazzi l'etica della
condivisione
io non faccio qualcosa per tenerlo per
me ma se io la faccia e la condivido con
un collega magari la prossima volta
riusciamo a fare di più realtà aumentata
cioè riesco a portare le cose
tradizionale con e aumentarle e metterci
di più
praticamente a scuola sarebbe bello
riuscire a insegnare l'innovazione ma
bisogna prima di tutto dare ragazzi la
creatività perché la creatività è quella
che mi mi permette di sognare qualche
cosa di diverso potrebbe in matematica
ne parliamo nell'astrazione
dell'astrazione in fondo è immaginazione
i miei studi sono io al liceo fatto
liceo classico perché era una zappa in
matematica
ho scoperto che in realtà quando si
utilizzano degli strumenti si possono
comprendere con duty sperimentare e
provare quando io sbaglio incomincia a
fare qualcosa da quel punto e perciò ho
cercato di pensare come potevo portare
la creatività anche in classe la
creatività è prima di tutto
immaginazione e talento
e talento nello scoprire per esempio
qualcosa del mondo che ci circonda
perché partire sempre dal del mondo
naturale
la creatività però è anche allenamento
fatica anche il calciatore che chi vuole
imparare a palleggiare deve esercitarsi
e la creatività e soprattutto metodo
perché il metodo quello che trasforma
qualcosa che è soltanto un'idea in
qualcosa di realizzabile metodo vuol
dire indagine parto dall'osservazione di
quello che c'è intorno
e poi pian piano cominciò a sviscerarne
il funzionamento e cerca di immaginare
qualcosa di nuovo che possa portare lì
perciò innovazione
secondo me non è creare qualcosa dal
nulla ma è ristrutturare qualcosa che
esiste per dare una nuova vita per
migliorarla a scuola è difficile però
noi dobbiamo preparare i ragazzi verso
questo perché come in tanti ci hanno
detto noi prepariamo dei ragazzi per
delle professioni che non è evidente non
esistono ancora
avevo ancora troppo pochi laureati in
materie stern scienze tecnologia
ingegneria e matematica
rispetto a quelli che vengono richiesti
la commissione europea sta organizzando
tantissime cose io però ho scritto stea
ma in realtà e stand perché asta per
arte ma sta anche per un approccio
olistico che include un potuto perché
pur inserendo matematica
forse anche perché mi piace parlare
condividere con i colleghi io credo che
sia importante insegnare il metodo
insegnare un po tutto non è soltanto
tecnologia per cui dobbiamo dare ai
ragazzi anche appunto l'idea di come
costruire qualcosa per insegnare la
geometria solida posso sicuramente usare
software come sketchup e andare a
estrudere delle forme ma posso anche
semplicemente a chieder loro di usare
gli spaghetti della plastilina per
vedere qual è la forma più stabile per
sostenere una struttura oppure posso
usare la robotica la robotica
io non sono appunto di approvazione non
è una formazione tecnologica la robotica
educativa è quel modo che risulta più
semplice per attrarre un pochino tutti
utilizzando dei giocattoli e il gioco è
quello che può essere bello stare a
scuola giocando il gioco è quello che ha
tra i ragazzi quello che conoscono ma
lordo una nuova vita a qualcosa
questa piegata sono io questo è il
disegno che mi ha fatto un mio studente
e rappresenta il lavoro nel curricolo
verticale perché io vado anche nella
scuola dell'infanzia
sapete a berlino dopo la caduta del muro
nella germania federale hanno fatto un
lavoro diciamo molto intenso per
rinnovare tutto per portare la scienza e
la tecnologia e all'ingegneria la
matematica fin dalla scuola
dell'infanzia robotica mi permette di
imparare concetti matematici vi permette
di parli di imparare a pensare a
lavorare in gruppo a utilizzare
linguaggio per iscrivermi a collegarmi
anche con scuole di altre parti del
mondo
le ragazze che di solito non sono brave
nelle materie scientifiche tecnologiche
diventano più brave se ci sono dei
modelli di ruolo riesco anche associando
alcune metodologie perché non è solo
robotica è proprio il sistema a
coinvolgere sempre più ragazze nel nel
lavoro perché servono anche le donne nel
in una società perché le donne per
esempio nella tecnologia sono quelle che
sono brave a trovare l'errore che hanno
perseveranza che hanno empatia come
diceva qualcuno inventare cose nuove il
guanto che un ragazzo ha inventato con
una tecnologia povera doveva servire
perché la nonna alla nonna che aveva
sempre il telecomando
ha pensato come posso far da far sì che
lei possa cambiare canale
allora ci sono modi nuovi per proporre
anche gli argomenti più difficili non il
libro di testo noioso ma problemi da
risolvere un robot che si deve
arrampicare su un su un piano inclinato
per esempio si possono diventare che
sufficiente aumentare un po la massa per
farlo salire ma la domanda inizia l'era
possa insegnare le innovazioni a scuola
e io insegno matematica
ogni tanto cento dei modi che colleghino
la matematica alla alla vita
allora cosa ci fa un ananas una mossa
come il girasole a una meravigliosa
armonia nella natura che coinvolge la
filo tasse cioè il fatto che le foglie
cercano di ottenere la maggior quantità
di luce possibile del sole per crescere
nel modo migliore addirittura turi si
era occupato dello studio di questa
regolarità e questa regolarità segue la
sequenza di fibonacci che vedete è
rappresentata con questi numeri qui
qualsiasi sia il numero di spire che che
otteniamo queste sono sempre legati a
sequenze fibonacci in questa in
particolare abbiamo le puntate ci sono 8
e 13 hanno un nastro di colore diverso
e allora dall'osservazione della natura
cosa si può fare di più se cerchiamo di
andare fa dagli schemi del think in
output box allora con i ragazzini
cerchiamo di provare a programmare
perché si parla di cose in code in
realtà è un codice non è necessariamente
guance tecnologico ma se io posso anche
provare gli effetti di quello che ho
appena sperimentato posso andare oltre
perciò noi non rimane soltanto
tecnologia ma diventa qualcosa in più
allora la cosa difficile come possono
riprodurre questo con un robot
questo è un robot educativo è un
giocattolo che i ragazzi già conoscono
le mie protesi voi adesso vedrete vi
farò vedere
un piccolo programma nel quale il robot
voglia ripercorrere la spirale aurea non
è un programma perfetto e un robot
partirà per per i fatti suoi
perché abbiamo usato un programma
scolastico e questo è un programma che
usiamo la scuola media
servirebbe imporre un controllo ma anche
l'errore il fatto the robot carta e che
non ci sia un controllo è proprio il
punto per progredire fino adesso mi
sembra arrivati fin qua cosa otterremo
poi dopo allora nel nel robot
addirittura p non si vede ci sono dei si
intravedono i numeri che girano seguendo
la spirale aurea e questo robot parte
pian pianino perché la sequenza 1 1 2 2
1 3 3 2 5 e poi avanti 5 3 8 e vedete
che la spirale aumenta sempre di più
poi il limite che questo può arrivare
solo 100 e perciò lui continuare a
girare finché a un certo punto partirà e
se ne andrà per la tangente perché non
proprio con quello che noi abbiamo fatto
adesso proseguire a chiudere la spirale
grazie